donc je commence par l'agenda comme
traditionnellement semaine du 24 au 30
octobre
lundi 24 octobre donc notre point presse
mardi 25 octobre à 18 heures nous aurons
une commission exécutive au siège des
républicains comme habituellement et
mercredi 26 octobre 19h réunion publique
en présence de laurent wauquiez
président des républicains à marcq en
baroeul
voilà pour l'agenda donc premier point
abordé on a choisi ce qui fait le coeur
de l'actualité ce matin c'est à dire
l'évacuation de la jungle à calais donc
voilà les différents réaction les
différentes réactions de notre mouvement
d'abord premièrement l'on considère que
le gouvernement a attendu beaucoup trop
longtemps avant de s'emparer de ce
problème
quatre années où on a vu petit à petit
cette jungle devenir de plus en plus
importante
le président de la république lui-même y
est allé très tardivement il n'a
d'ailleurs même pas pris l'initiative
d'aller à l'intérieur de la jungle pour
voir ce qu'il s'y passait il faut
constater également que pendant ces
années il ya eu absence de recherche
total d'autres solutions pour permettre
de résoudre ce problème que je vais
évoquer un petit peu plus loin avec
notamment le problème du droit d'asile
ensuite deuxième remarque on ne résout
pas le problème du calaisis mais on le
déplace à d'ailleurs été noté par gagner
que le bihan de médecins du monde
récemment puisqu'un certain nombre même
un grand nombre de migrants à calais ne
souhaite pas quitter calais parce qu'ils
veulent absolument aller en grande
bretagne est donc déjà maintenant
d'ailleurs on voit un certain nombre
d'entre eux quitté cette jungle pour
investir des endroits pour s'y cacher
pour pouvoir par la suite allait comme
il le souhaite sur la grande bretagne
d'ailleurs dans mon département nous
avions eu il ya quelques temps un
certain nombre de réfugiés qui avaient
été à
i ils sont restés une semaine ils sont
repartis immédiatement vers calais parce
qu'il voulait absolument aller au
royaume uni donc voilà problème du
déplacement de ce problème et on risque
d'avoir finalement au lieu de cette
jungle est bien plein de petits endroits
autour de calais qui vont constituer des
ptic en moins visibles mais avec les
mêmes problèmes
troisième remarque nous sommes face à un
déni de démocratie de la part de ce
gouvernement qui méprise complètement la
maire de calais qui n'a pas été ni
consultés ni associée aux différentes
décisions qui ont été prises pire les
maires de france n'ont également pas été
consulté par les préfets dans les
territoires pour voir comment organiser
cet accueil pourtant c'est dommage
un certain nombre d'entre eux avait eu
quelques idées pouvaient avoir envie de
choisir
l'accueil de quelques migrants sur leur
territoire au lieu de ça ce sont les
préfets qui ont organisé avec des
populations en nombre très important
parfois eux qui décale les équilibres
démographiques dans des petites communes
rurales
donc on a des cendres avec 30 35 50
voire 60 personnes qui vont arriver
nécessitant d'ailleurs des travaux pour
pouvoir les les accueillir enfin
quatrième point on voit effectivement
que l'évacuation pour le moment se passe
bien sur le calaisis je voudrais
simplement rappeler qu'il ya quand même
19 compagnies de crs pour encadrer cette
cette manoeuvre de déplacement mais que
nous sommes pour le moment sur la partie
favorable de ce déplacement puisqu'il ya
un certain nombre de migrants qui sont
actuellement à calais qui ont qui
aspirera du répit aspire à vivre autre
chose qui sont plutôt volontaire et qui
se sont présentés assez spontanément
pour pouvoir quitter cette cette jungle
et bénéficier des différents transports
qui leur sont leur sont proposés ça va
devenir sûrement un petit peu plus
compliqué quand on va essayer de
déplacer ce qu'ils veulent absolument
rester sur calais pour partir vers la
grande bretagne
enfin j'en terminerai avec la
problématique du droit d'asile
qui est le nôtre en france puisque c'est
cette problématique qui nous permet de
faire la différence entre des migrants
deux des personnes des hommes des femmes
des enfants qui sont réellement menacés
chez eux et pour lesquels effectivement
nous devons instruire un droit d'asile
et nous devons pouvoir leur proposer de
de leur sauver la vie
carrément et puis les autres qui sont
des migrants économiques est pour le
moment bien tout ce tout ce monde est un
peu mélangés donc je vous rappelle les
règles quand même
en france elles sont pour instruire les
dossiers des migrants elles sont de six
mois plus 3 mois s'il ya des difficultés
encore trois mois donc on a à peu près
un an d'instruction est dans la réalité
on est pratiquement aux deux années
d'instruction donc vous imaginez bien
que deux ans d'instruction d'un dossier
de demande d'asile
c'est très compliqué de faire repartir
chez eux dès des familles d'autant plus
qu' on scolarise obligatoirement les
enfants dans notre pays et que depuis de
la circulaire de monsieur valls en 2012
il est impossible de d'expulser des
parents d'enfants qui sont scolarisés
donc en fait dès qu'une famille entre
clandestinement et arrive sur le
territoire français est bien chez nous
il n'ya plus d'exclusion possible donc
je voudrais rappeler quelques chiffres
30 me le demande d'asile en 2011 60
mille demandes d'asile en 2014 80 mille
demandes d'asile en 2015 31% de ses 2 2
en 2015 31% sont acceptés donc 69%
déboutés et donc sur ses 69 déboutés qui
représente 55 mille personnes
expulsables seulement 2200 personnes ont
été expulsées
c'est dire l'ampleur du problème tels
que nous pouvons le vivre en france et
c'est dire la nécessité que nous avons
de réformer cette demande c'est ce droit
d'asile dans le pays est simplement pour
rajouter un élément qui d'ailleurs m'a
été soufflée par notre député européen
c'est que en allemagne une partie de la
manne on vient de modifier cette réforme
du droit d'asile et les délais sont
passés à sept jours plus éventuellement
sept jours dont vous voyez deux ans
nous alors que ça c'est un en fait
inscrit dans les textes et ça passe à
deux ans et les allemands ont été plus
réactifs et ils sont passés à sept jours
voire 14 jours donc voilà il ya beaucoup
à faire pour pouvoir gérer ce problème y
compris d'ailleurs sur la scène
internationale pour pouvoir gérer ce
problème beaucoup mieux que ce que le
gouvernement a fait jusqu'à présent
voilà j'enchaîne sur les manifestations
de policiers qui se sont déroulées tout
au long de la semaine dernière et qui
vont se poursuivre cette semaine encore
un mouvement spontané un mouvement
massif
plus d'un millier de deux fonctionnaires
de police qui manifestent c'est quelque
chose d'inédit de jamais vu et je
voudrais revenir rapidement sur les
causes de ces manifestations
tout d'abord l'épuisement l'épuisement
des troupes avec un taux de présence de
près de 80% on évoquera évidemment le
contexte des attentats mais aussi de
toutes les manifestations qui se sont
déroulées en france cette année la coop
21 à l'euro les manifestations contre la
loi travailler puis le traitement de la
délinquance car cette dernière
évidemment ne s'est pas arrêtée dans le
contexte d'attentats que nous
connaissons et ça me rappelle la funeste
prévision d'un théoricien de dèche qui
disait que dans la stratégie à mettre en
oeuvre les plus demandés forces de
police étaient 1 d une des méthodes pour
parvenir à leurs fins donc on a bien une
situation d'épuisement de nos de nos
policiers
deuxièmement ils sont devenus des cibles
depuis charlie manière ville
viry châtillon on voit que nos policiers
sont devenus des cibles et au fond comme
l'a dit un responsable de la droite un
candidat aux primaires c'est le monde à
l'envers
ce sont les policiers qui désormais
expriment clairement leur peur de n'être
plus respectés et et même de voir leur
vie mise en danger
j'ai été frappé par le témoignage de
plusieurs d'entre eux qui évoquait la
crâne de leur famille et notamment de
leurs enfants qui les voit partir tous
les jours au travail et qui expriment
leur angoisse de ne pas les ans voir
revenir
il critique également les tâches qu'ils
estiment être un dû comme les gardes
statiques là des exemples les plus
aberrants je dirais c'est la gare de
statique d'une caméra
en principe on met de la
vidéosurveillance et de la
vidéoprotection pour venir épauler les
forces de police
et là il faut des policiers pour garder
les caméras donc on voit bien qu'on est
arrivé à un système qui frise l'absurde
donc les tâches indues qui les
détournent de leur mission première
et puis je dirais que une des raisons
majeures sans doute dont on n'a pas fini
de délivrer les conséquences funestes
c'est bien sûr le désarmement pénale le
désarmement pénale induits par les loi
taubira pour avoir participé au débat
sur les lois taubira les la suppression
des peines planchers le la suppression
de l'incarcération
je l'avais dit en son temps à l'ami au
gala garde des sceaux vous êtes dans une
idéologie anti carcéral la prison est
devenue était aux yeux de madame taubira
dangereuse et je rappelle tout de même
que tout le programme de construction de
places de prison qui avaient été engagés
sous le précédent quinquennat a été tout
de même interrompu et on voit bien les
limites de ces décisions qui étaient
purement idéologique dont on voit les
effets catastrophiques sur le terrain
les policiers arrêtent et il n'y a aucun
suivi judiciaire et ça c'est quand même
assez terrible ils se font défié par des
jeunes par de très jeunes délinquants
sans qu'il n'y ait de réponse appropriée
donc il y a véritablement une perte de
sens de leurs de leur travail de leur
fonction de leur place même dans la
société
les policiers n'ont plus confiance plus
confiance dans les institutions plus
confiance dans le pouvoir
je rappelle pour mémoire tout de même
les mots malheureux même scandaleux du
ministre de l'intérieur qui à propos de
l'agression dont ont été victimes les
policiers qui ont deux d'entre eux ont
failli mourir
il a parlé de sauvages ans c'est comme à
propos de l'agression de ce proviseur de
ceux de ce professeur qui a eu la
mâchoire cassée
on parle d'une altercation donc les
mollahs dénis la réalité des fêtes c'est
très grave parce que ça commence par là
et je pense que la colère des policiers
se nourrit aussi de ce déni de réalité
qui qui est celle des pouvoirs publics
et j'ajoute enfin que le discrédit va
jusqu'au plus haut sommet de l'état avec
le président de la république qui se
commet en propos qui dévalorise non
seulement sa fonction sa personne mais
aussi sa fonction et du coup on voit
bien que toute la chaîne de
responsabilités s'en trouve affectée et
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles les policiers sont en perte
de confiance totale
alors comme le 15 noeuds le ministre
15,9 ne peux pas répondre sur le fond un
qui est vraiment cette perte de sens et
ce désarmement pénale eh bien il répond
par les moyens comme toujours il répond
par les moyens on va mettre davantage de
moyens
je rappelle à ce sujet que contrairement
à ce qui est affirmé par le gouvernement
socialiste
et je prends je prends pour preuve le
rapport la cour des comptes à la fin de
l'année 2015 il y avait huit cent
soixante huit policiers et gendarmes de
moins que sous nicolas sarkozy que sous
le quinquennat précédent
je parle de postes effectivement occupé
de poste
effectivement occupés donc je je je nie
absolument l'analyse qui en est faite
par le gouvernement socialiste
et si véritablement il y avait un
problème d'effectif eh bien il fallait
qu'il s'en préoccupent avant la fin du
quinquennat
donc pour toutes ces réponses pour
toutes ces raisons nous comprenons bien
que cette fronde
elle est inquiétante et c'est le mot de
conclusion que j'aurai ce qui est
inquiétant à la fois pour les policiers
mais aussi pour l'ensemble de la
population
c'est que ces policiers qui sont les
garants de l'ordre public disent qu'ils
ne sont plus en mesure de l'exercer et
ça c'est véritablement une situation des
plus alarmantes dont le gouvernement
devrait prendre toute la mesure
transition avant philippe
dans ce désert politique bien présenter
à la fois par bérengère et annie sur des
thématiques qui préoccupe
particulièrement nos compatriotes
en ce moment nous voulions revenir sur
eux ce week end sur ce week end lunaire
de la part du parti socialiste
donc la france est en train de couler
les problèmes économiques sociaux
sécuritaires s'amoncellent
jour après jour et le parti socialiste
qui apportait déjà depuis 2012 le
quinquennat de l'impuissance publique
on y revient chaque lundi matin est en
train de sombrer dans le quinquennat de
l'indécence j'en veux pour preuve les
déclarations ahurissantes du premier
ministre monsieur valls qui est dans un
grand meeting à tour il ya quelques
jours aux déclaré chers amis socialistes
nous devons être fiers parce que nous
avons redresser l'économie de la france
et réhabiliter l'autorité de l'état et
qu'à ce titre ils s'imaginent déjà en
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
c'est la même chose pour madame royal si
j'ai bien compris toutes les gazettes du
week-end puisque elle commence à y
songer sérieusement sans doute parce
qu'elle est fier du bilan qui fut le
sien à la tête de la région poitou
charentes qu'elle redresse à avec une
telle réussite qu'aujourd'hui les dettes
et les déficits de cette région sont si
considérable que le nouveau président de
région de la nouvelle région
pourtant son ami socialiste a entamé un
certain nombre de procédures pour
identifier où se trouvaient les fautes
lourdes de madame royal dans la gestion
de sa région on entend aussi beaucoup
monsieur macron qui prétend aller à
cette élection présidentielle
lui dont personne ne doit oublier qu'il
fut le conseiller économique de monsieur
hollande en 2011 qu'il fut le secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée chargé des
questions économiques entre 2012 et 2014
il fut le ministre de l'économie entre
août et l'été 2016 et que par conséquent
à moins qu'on nous contredisent nous as
est ici ministre de l'économie en france
est l'un des plus hauts postes de la
république avec des moyens
d'intervention et d'action monumentaux
les 6 millions de chômeurs en france
pire encore on vient de découvrir qu'il
y a près de 9 millions de français qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté rapport
présenté la semaine dernière un million
de plus sous le quinquennat de françois
hollande
et on pourrait continuer les
présentations avec monsieur montebourg
qui prétend s'emparer du thème du
patriotisme économique probablement
veut-il parlé d' alstom de peugeot de
florange et de toutes ces réussites
industrielles du quinquennat de françois
hollande on voit bien
l'indécence de la gauche et l'indécence
du parti socialiste qui plutôt que de
parler aux français d'apporter des
réponses aux problèmes des français se
regarde le nombril on voit bien
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agit probablement
puisque ils ont déjà enterré
politiquement françois hollande
il s'agit probablement de la seule
succession en france dont personne ne
disputent l'héritage c'est à dire
personne ne veut du bilan tant qu'il est
catastrophique mais tout le monde veut
la place et c'est tout ce qui est en
train de se tramer depuis ces derniers
jours avec encore plus de violence tout
au long du week end et tout au long des
semaines et des mois qui s'annoncent
donc après ce quinquennat de
l'impuissance nous sommes en train de
basculer dans le trimestre de
l'indécence où le parti socialiste bien
incapable de régler les problèmes des
français s'amuse de candidature en
candidature et nous chez les
républicains
nous dénonçons cette incapacité à
regarder la réalité en face et que
toutes les candidatures évoqué ces
derniers jours sont des candidatures il
légitime à nos yeux tant ceux qui
prétendent les incarner ont échoué
lamentablement et lourdement à la tête
dans notre pays et aux plus hautes
fonctions de l'état nous souhaitions
revenir en quelques mots sur cette
situation
c'est philippe sur les questions
européennes le parlement européen se
réunit cette semaine à strasbourg et
donc les sujets sont acier a passé de
nombreux je vais peut-être abordé trois
ou quatre le premier est un sujet
d'actualité dont on parle beaucoup
depuis quelques jours c'est celui du
traité avec le canada le ceta et se
traiter sur le fond est un traité comme
ans que je pourrais qualifier bien mais
peut mieux faire c'est à dire que très
clairement un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs vont être mieux protégés
il y aura plus de roquefort canadien il
y aura plus de camembert canadien ce qui
est plutôt une bonne chose
en revanche la production bovine peut
être altérée par ce traité puisqu'elle
permet d importation de viande bovine en
france alors même que nous sommes
excédentaires donc ça posera un problème
et l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
auront à connaître les différents
aspects les plus précis du traité et se
détermineront alors ce qui nous frappe
dans cette affaire c'est que cette
discussion sur la position des wallons
est une position qui montrent qu'au fond
l'europe à 28 avec la gouvernance telle
qu'elle existe et très très
difficilement gouvernable
dans le meilleur des cas si l'on est
favorable au traité
on pourrait imaginer au moins quatre ans
de procédure à partir de maintenant pour
que tous les parlements nationaux adopte
le texte
ce qui montre que dans une
mondialisation qui est extrêmement
rapide
manifestement l'union européenne est
aujourd'hui pas armés pour avoir un mode
de gouvernance adaptée à une nécessité
de décisions rapides
on peut pas négocier depuis 2011 un
traité et attendre encore à partir de
2016 quatre ans éventuellement pour le
ratifier
on va vraiment qu'il ya un vrai sujet
nous ne nous ne partageons pas du tout
les critiques qui sont faites à l'égard
des dés de nos voisins wallons qui ont
tout à fait démocratiquement
évidemment le droit de s'opposer à un
accord puisque c'est ainsi que nous
avons décidé de faire fonctionner la
robe dans le cas d'un accord mixte donc
il est extrêmement ça c'est le deuxième
point tout à fait critiquable de
critiquer les oiseaux qui ne font que
finalement appliquer des règles certes
imparfaite mais direct que nous
some donner collectivement deuxième
point sur la question du breakbeat le
break site a fait l'objet de deux points
d'actualité un peu un peu à peu
actualisées puisque la première ministre
lors du sommet du conseil européen est
venu prendre la parole sur ce sujet nous
nous voulons pointer un élément qui nous
paraît absolument capital c'est
qu'actuellement il y à 8000 entreprises
européennes et cinq mille cinq cents
entreprises britanniques qui veulent qui
ont besoin du passeport européen alors
qu'elles sont installés sur le
territoire de la grande bretagne le
passeport européen à cet outil
administratif qui permet de faire du
commerce et des échanges commerciaux
avec tout le reste de l'union européenne
si le breakbeat quand le brésil aura
lieu va avoir lieu mais quand il aura
lieu ces entreprises devront par
nécessité rejoindre le continent pour
continuer à développer leurs activités
économiques et donc il s'agit de la
manne de plusieurs milliers
d'entreprises qui cherchent un point
d'ancrage alors aujourd'hui quelles sont
les villes qui sont prêtes à accueillir
il ya dublin qui a quelques avantages en
particulier linguistique yak francfort
qui a quelques avantages en particulier
de sérieux germanique
et puis à paris et nous trouvons
républicain absolument incroyable que le
gouvernement continue à prendre ça avec
une extrême légèreté et il a fallu que
ce soit la région ile-de-france valérie
pécresse ou le conseil général des
hauts-de-seine patrick devedjian qui
prennent l'affairé en main et qui a
montré aux britanniques
tout l'intérêt qu'il y aurait à venir
s'installer en france
cette question du bric site est la
conséquence de l'installation des
actuels sociétés qui sont sur le sol
britannique en france va être un
témoignage de notre crédibilité
économique et nous demandons au
gouvernement français de tout faire pour
que les entreprises furent veut puissent
venir sur notre territoire et de prendre
exemple sur ce que fait la région ile de
france
est ce que fait le conseil général des
hauts-de-seine troisième sujet peut être
enfin c'est un sujet qui est européen au
sens où il impliquait la france et
l'allemagne
vous savez que la direction générale de
l'armement la tva
passer un marché public pour doter
l'armée française d'un fusil d'assaut le
fusil d'assaut actuel de l'armée
française et le fusil famas et le fusil
famas va arrêter d'être en dotation et
va être remplacé par un fusil qui est
finalement le fusiller allemand hk 416
hk tout le monde a compris c'est
l'acronyme de la société allemande qui
fournit ce fusil c'est la société est
clair et koch chaos ch et cette société
a été choisie par la dg a à l'issue d'un
appel d'offres ce que nous regrettons
sur l'appel d'offres c'est que
premièrement manifestement désormais le
budget militaire français va servir à
améliorer la balance commerciale
allemande que deuxièmement il y avait un
concurrent français qui avait essayé de
concourir à l'appel d'offres qui a été
d'emblée rejeté par la digère à un seul
troisièmement qu'il y avait un italien
beretta qui lui a une usine dans la
loire qui aurait pu produire sur le sol
français qui n'a pas été retenu et enfin
le belge herstal accepté lui également
de fabriquer une partie des éléments du
fusil d'assaut à tulsa aurait dû
peut-être stimuler le président de
république est bien lui non plus n'a pas
été retenu et donc nous avons donné ce
marché public fondamental pour
l'indépendance nationale c'est le fusil
d'assaut de l'armée française pour les
20 ans à venir à une société allemande
qui ne délocalisera manifestement aucun
emploi sur le territoire national et qui
semble-t-il est déjà elle même en
difficulté financière c'est un budget de
300 à 400 millions qui au fond va
nourrir comme je le disais la balance
commerciale allemande
en ponctionnant le budget de la défense
française enfin dernier point peut-être
rapide les eurodéputés devront se
prononcer demain sur la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire de jean marie
le pen qui était accusé de propos
absolument incroyable puisqu'il s'en
était pris au chanteur patrick bruel en
déclarant j'ouvre les guillemets on fera
une fournée la prochaine fois c'est
évidemment parole est absolument
scandaleuse
nous voterons la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire et nous regarderons avec
intérêt la position de marine le pen et
du groupe politique de marine le pen sur
cette levée d'immunité parlementaire